he takes up that space and puts so much
pressure on you at the rim
middleton he hasn't had one yet so it's
his turn i guess
andy honest now this is the area of his
game they want to challenge him
but he's done a good job he's really
improved this year even though he's only
31 percent
[Music]
janus high post against moore lost the
dribble for a split second turns
and it is pure right through for yannis
out of the cumbo
he's also a leading candidate for
defensive player of the year
a writer from salt lake city giannis on
cue
goes to the basket and the schroeder
averages more minutes per game than
giannis as a sixth
that was postponed on march 11th they
were the final scheduled game that night
it was called off they were playing
sacramento
giannis knocks down the three so much of
what we're seeing is intentional jim
is originally from west bend currently
an er
doctor in indianapolis he's a huge bucks
fan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for the pelicans j.j redick
knocks down the three
[Applause]
books scrambling in that defense jj
reddick hits it in the corner
we're going to know about everything in
the boat everything
even when you leave too finding his way
down the paint
finger roll for him the bucks have the
largest
point differential in the league talking
about
jj reddick hits the three
we've got it all tied again jj redick
from deep
so happy to see you healthy and in
orlando can't wait for you to get back
on the court
josh hart comes up with the steal j.j
reddick what you call a heat check
[Applause]
he has never missed a playoff appearance
he told zion williamson when we have to
get
those crunch time minutes and that
crunch time roll going
there's the roll speeding on us he can
pretty much do it anytime
and this bucks team came out so hot in
the first two games we have to remember
this is still a period where everybody
is starting to get into the swing of
things although
giannis does look like he's in
mid-season form with that spin move
collecting himself and finishing out the
rim